real 92 3 bootleg cab show East Side
Johnny come on now Jay Rock come on
imagine let him know I can't believe
it's been five years since we got that
album bro you you posted that the other
day or somebody posted it and I could
not I had to really in my head go back
and be like damn it's been five years
since you dropped hey man
because in fact when you ain't really
thinking about pandemic happened
yesterday and then you plaqued up yeah
he says man it was just like it was
yesterday man hey that that combust
thing don't put a stop to a lot of
things though for sure now listen I
gotta say I don't think we've really sat
I mean we've seen each other of course
but we haven't sat down in front of a
camera since you've gotten your plaques
and gotten the Grammy [__] and all that
I just want to say I'm proud of you man
man you already know man I appreciate
you bro yeah like I say we go way back
like four flats I remember when y'all
were riding around in the in the van the
TDE van in like 2010 the Warner days a
lot of people understand that grind
right there man like like people won't
even believe it yeah the way things is
now
and believe that type of grind like I
say like people don't understand the
things we went through to get to where
we were right man as far as grind wise I
mean [__] with tech nine dropping them
out with strange like so much going into
it man a lot of things transpired and
like I say man and I'm still here man
still still here hungry that's a
blessing so you've been taking your time
with this album yes and you're known to
drop classic bodies of work this got to
be no different man how tell me about
the new album oh man the new album is
great man like I was just telling
everybody man everybody's like man you
just what's taking you so long man five
years man you know all the fans been
beating me up on right Instagram and all
that but uh it's just about making good
quality music like I said I'm trying to
do an album like my last one where you
ain't got to skip no skip I don't know
if you've ever had an album where
there's a skip saying it's just I don't
want nobody just to man they listen on
man right just get the [__] so I'm
trying I'm just trying to do an album
like that and you know I mean people
know why man it's Jay Rock come on man
you know what I can wrap circles around
a lot of people but you know hey are you
talking your [__] who call them out I'm
just saying come on say it I'm just
saying this drop one name
[Laughter]
for sure it's funny because I was just
having a off-camera conversation with a
good friend of ours and I was just
talking about like somehow when we talk
about the grand scheme of West Coast rap
I don't think when we talk about like
the greatest of all time conversation
you get mention enough because you have
so much to do with
everything bro yeah yeah and you are
consistent and that's why I was so dope
to see you finally get like a hit record
like the king's disease you know what
I'm saying like right and so for you
like getting a little taste of like
getting in the car turning on the radio
and hearing your [__] in regular
rotation
what's the approach like did you make
sure we had I mean we talked about the
hypothetical song really yeah I'm
assuming we got some some some hits on
this album yeah hey the hits is coming
man amen the hints is crazy they knock
out blows for sure uh yeah man uh uh
like I said man I've just been taking my
time staying focused and just like I
said I don't want to come out sounding
like everybody else you feel me and
that's that been my whole goal right
that's how he was back in the days you
know the grind of course like radio
records trying to finish I mean [__]
your first big single was a Wayne yeah
you were trying to fit into the you know
I mean what was going on with the you
know with the edms whatever y'all call
them BPM yeah right whatever you know
rotation but I just you know what like I
say you just got to be true to yourself
and stay true to your craft and stay
true to what you trying to do and
everything else will fall into place and
that's when that's how it's going right
okay uh I know you got some big features
on this album yeah I heard there's a big
female rapper on a song
I heard there's a very a very
multi-talented uh
last question I got for you is there
anybody in the black hippie crew on the
album oh yeah of course okay of course
can you
okay
he's one of the ones who started the
black people crew okay so we got the
black hippie representation for sure you
got a black history representative on
there that's what I like to hear man hey
in the record crazy and the record's
crazy record is crazy and he hey he
kicking some [__] listen the new song's
Tuesday East Side East Side 627 man make
sure I'll be on the lookout Jay rocks
and album now let's go man my guy hey
yeah man yeah I don't know what's going
on you know what I'm saying but uh yeah
[__] I don't know either man I've just
been hearing through the grapevine [__]
I could be wrong or right we prayed
before you came in appreciate you
appreciate you folks